regardez les rats ce fléau qui sèment la
terreur auprès des populations mais sans
dans les campagnes dans les mines
ils sont des dizaines de millions à
déambuler chaque soir dans les rues de
france aux normales un choc l'heure
depuis le confinement ils ont déserté
les égouts ces rongeurs peu farouches
attaque désormais aux habitations faute
de nourriture
alors que faut-il faire comment les
éradiquer ces coûts et surtout des raves
antique dominer le monde
sten il avait dit que s'il aura il avait
la taille de l'homme se serait lui le
maître du monde
voilà alors elle à l'aller la déchire
ig2i magenta lors qu'on va revoir la
dira c'est incroyable et on a avec le
ruben savoir humaine ça vingt ans merci
d'être là ruben et ruben une histoire
incroyable gérant d'une société de
dératisation
c'est ça s'arrête dans la dératisation
c'est ça ça va ça se passe bien ça se
passe très bien et on a avec nous
également alors c'est paul ouais vous
êtes ancien dératiseur c'est sa proue
vous devez arrêter qu'est ce qui s'est
passé parce que vous avez connu une très
mauvaise expérience
j'aimerais que vous nous raconter votre
histoire en fait je me réveille comme
tous les matins en fait je m'en vais des
interventions dont vous étiez de
travailler ensemble mais exactement très
bien donc on m'envoie une intervention
comme tous les matins je vais à
l'intervention donc c'est quoi une
intervention s'était ou des rats où ça
c'est d'un quatrième à paris d'accord
dans une maison un appartement mais au
rez-de-chaussée d'accord à côté il y
avait un restaurant accor et la dame
affolée mj venez vite
gg l'erreur j'ai peur donc moi je me dis
bon c'est pas grave c'est comme
d'habitude tout le monde a peur même
coach a bien sûr oui et je rentre dans
la cuisine
enfin je fais mon diagnostic tout ça je
rends dans la cuisine j'ouvre les
placards il ya sans mentir c'est tout
ira qui sortent de nulle part alors
c'était mon métier
bien sûr j'ai angoisses et j'ai eu très
peur je suis parti j'ai couru chez eux
mêmes peu j'ai atterri sur un canapé et
non les radis vraiment à la maison
une angoisse pas possible mais ils ont
couru donc toucher cours une autre la
maison au moment où va donc vous êtes le
gaillard a qui courent après moi je
voulais vous attaquer c'est un truc de
fou ils sont tous en fait comme la dame
et les avaient enfermés dix ans les
péchés de sortir il a ouvert le jeu moi
j'ai ouvert le placard c'est écrit sol
belge était tout seul face à lui ras on
passe à la voile a eu d'accord j'ai
couru je sortais la cuisine j'ai couru
son canapé ils sont ils sont partis dans
toute la maison la dame affolée elle
crie partout elle m'angoisse encore plus
ab non non non d'ouvrir la porte qui
alors acquis mac imac mac rattraper la
jambe mais il m'a mordu mais non et
partent panique j'ai pas j'ai pas tout
de suite c'est le jeu c'est que j'ai eu
mal qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire vacciner
j'ai fait j'ai justement je suis rentré
chez moi après j'ai vu que j'avais mal
et ça commençait à me lancer j'ai eu
peur pas du coup qu'est ce que je suis
fait je suis parti à l'hôpital et ils
m'ont fait un vaccin un vaccin contre la
rage et où ça fait mal aux reins en fait
avec l'adrénaline comme j'ai eu très
peur
ma page et j'ai pas tout de suite senti
j'aimerais tout de suite sentiers mais
avec l'adrénaline j'ai choisi mais ça
fait ça fait vraiment très peur ah oui
je vous sont nés dans mort à serain ça
fait vraiment très peur je vous garantis
et donc vous avez décidé d'arrêter après
voilà j'ai arrêté baptisé on va être
rebaptisée du quoi et pourquoi alors
qu'est ce que vous en train de me dire
alors parce que vous êtes dératiseur
ruben gérant d'une société de
dératisation c'est vrai ce que c'est
vrai que les rats ont beaucoup moins
peur des hommes maintenant bien sûr bas
comme mon technicien vont était en train
de le raconter aujourd'hui de plus en
plus justement les rats n'ont plus peur
parce que déjà avec le l'histoire du
confinement en ce moment donc il y avait
plus personne dans les rues donc ce qui
a fait que justement en ce moment l'une
des races sont sentis chez eux mais ça
va j'ai senti chez moi j'ai vu des
rentrées ont cherché à nous dominons
mais c'est vrai quoi les bras ils se
disent ils ont plus peur ils ont plus
peur du tout ouais et est donc est-ce
qu'ils sont dangereux serra ah oui très
dangereux bien sûr c'est à dire c'est
très dangereux
ces vecteurs de maladies donc c'est un
peu faux absolument rien sur déjà
vacciné contre contre la rage contre ça
ça peut amener beaucoup de maladies et
évidemment c'est très très dangereux
parce qu'encore il paraît que maintenant
ils s'aventurent de plus en plus dans
les habitations
avant il restait de loi mais pourquoi
ils vont maintenant dans les habitations
isabelle aussi oui on a on n'a pas eu
des censeurs
comme il ya vu des réalisations dans
lesquels ils se sont réfugiés dans la
cage de senseurs et dont je vous fais
les câbles et dons et les personne ne
voulait venir s'occuper des rats qui ont
proliféré dans la cage de sang jr dans
ma famille nous avons subi récemment une
attaque de rappeler mangerai sur la
toile dans le 15e arrondissement de
paris un appartement au dernier étage
c'est une cousine qui a ouvert la porte
de sa salle de bain et qui a vu un
énorme raz non juste au dessus des
toilettes donc c'est ça alors je vous
dis pas ça par les canalisations les
rails ça et vous il faut bien fermer la
cuvette doit l'aider à chaque fois et ça
c'est vrai parce que pouvez vous aurez
moins un pote à moi qui suis réveillé la
nuit c'est pareil il avait un rat sur sa
cuvette jure que c'est vrai il m'a dit
comme ça exactement sans rigoler les
bouchons comme ça qu'on sortait de l'eau
le rac one a en poche total le rat il
arrivait je vous jure que c'est vrai ces
pagnes il a déménagé d'ailleurs il a eu
tellement peur qu'il a déménagé trading
a ouvert les toilettes
ah oui ronde par les privatisations des
rennais freinés à ses empreintes de fait
ça s'arrêterait rarement les ragots sur
duke ne sont pas pour le jeu sera très
agressif très agressif de qu'elle a
créée la refermer la porte
première équipe de dératisation est venu
c'était qui plane et n était pas en
combinaison ils sont repartis sont
revenus à 2 avant mes combinaisons
gilbert leroux s'est même hyper agressif
a une histoire de fous les rats en ce
moment à quoi cette équipe là font parce
que tout le monde dit que les rats ils
peuvent prendre le contrôle de certaines
grandes villes et oui je vous le dis il
voit que de plus en plus les humains eux
deux oui et ils prennent ils prennent la
confiance il admire ciara vraiment lui
mettre un coup de son prix voilà si vous
vous trouvez face à face et kara faut
pas faire genre on a peur c'est que si
ce tarif tôt alors vous avez raison
pendant le conflit crever la faim parce
que les radiations et fermé oui et donc
ils attaquent les câbles électriques
parce qu'ils sont bien mais avec de
l'amidon c'est ça dont il adore l'amidon
est en fait le rat et c'est très
dangereux parce qu'il a besoin toujours
d'user cesser ses incisives besoin de
lits mais parce que les incisives dur à
tous de 1 cm par an et donc il faut tout
le temps qu'il était c'est qu'ils les
abîmes et c'est pour ça que c'est très
dangereux et ça vous a mordu avec mama
la grèce et je veux dire ouais ouais
j'ai une histoire j'ai un copain qui a
des nac nouveaux animaux de compagnie et
ou alors il est il le dit tout ça tout
le monde le sait il faut faire des
papiers pour les avoir tout ça je vous
n'en est pas une c'est pas une vanne je
vous dire que c'est vrai et c'est un
copain moi un très bon ami à moi
qu'ils s'appellent nicholas tiko je vous
le recevrez il
il a des serpents il donne à manger des
rats c'est certain il a pris un rat ils
ont dernièrement il a pris laura laura
s'est énervé laura a mordu le serpent il
a tué le serpent je vous jure que c'est
vrai c'est pas c'est pas ces lois une
banane est ce que les rats pourquoi est
long et il faut vraiment nous attaquer
ils peuvent vraiment nous attaquer parce
qu'il cherche si vous voulez à manger à
se nourrir
d'accord donc nous attaquer il attaque
où les rats c'est à dire comment ça se
passe si on se retrouve face à un rapace
qu'en fait vous nous appelez mais s'il
aura m'attaque je défonce s'il ce que je
fais sendra vous attaquent la seule
chose à faire ce qu'il faut le prendre
là c'est souvent parce bessire il faut
se sauver il faut aussi aura devant soi
faut faut partir faut pas vraiment pas
vraiment ils n'ont pas peur du tout hein
c'est pas c'est plus comme avant et
c'est plus les rats d'avant c'est vers
l'avant les races à revenir à l'avant à
paris en tenir là du tout ouais c'est à
dire s'il aura peut-être un rack peuvent
attaquer oui bien sûr donc ils char à la
maison il attaque imaginons ils
attaquent maisons font que fait quoi je
suis allée à l'hôpital dans un premier
temps tous les cas la loterie tas
d'idées dans la chambre avec les entoure
moi j'en serais humain un coup de balai
non mais non sans rigoler qui sortaient
de la mine
vous sortez sortez ya que des molécules
professionnels peuvent aujourd'hui tout
est deja civis est parce que je vous
explique tôt il ya un rat si vous voulez
ouais forcément il est avec tout ça
toute sa famille derrière l'histoire
sociale voilà exactement c'est la
famille dira voilà non mais c'est un
truc de ouf
donc vous est ce que vous êtes de plus
en plus appelés oui oui de plus en plus
surtout en ce moment
enfin ces dernières années avec le grand
paris les travaux du grand paris que
toutes les si vous voulez tous les sols
ont été retournées donc les rats sortent
de plus en plus et se sentent de plus en
plus chez eux dans paris c'est
incroyable ça fait non mais ça peut
faire flipper pas sa peine et les chats
ne les attaque pas alors les chats les
attaques mais parce qu'on m'a toujours
dit font un challenger alors les chats
ça marche
les chats n'a pas collé à l'oreille
quand rc fois pour les travaux
ce qu'il faut à la maison alors les
chassa voulez ça peut manger des petites
souris et pradera par contre les races
et les robes qui vient d'attaquer les
champs c'est vraiment un jour les
chalossais d'apple mara enchères a peur
d'un rabais à un pitbull enchère ils ont
peur des chiens ils ont peur déchire les
reins ça ils ont qu'à un pitbull moi
même par bwin com
c'est un pitbull peut tuer aura
facilement faut savoir qu'un rat ça
attaque en colonie sa vie en colonie ça
vient on est d'accord
ouais c'est lâche accord très bien
nicolas dire quelque chose
non je suis très surpris que les chats
et peur de rien parce que c'est moi je
peux rien c'est l'info du passé mais de
plus en plus on voit les jolis c'est la
faute du jour et protège en plus on voit
les espèces de chez plus qu on appelle
ça ira gondole acquis at a su acquérir
les poules et les trucs
ouais mais c'est aux angoisses ont
commencé et là vous mettez bien en quoi
ces week-ends vous avez le rat des
champs et le rat des villes non pas des
champs est plutôt correcte et un petit
peu à l'ancienne
sa parade les smart a boudé le
reconnaître leurs habits chauds il
habite un petit perdu non
il a des petites îles à désespoir rio
pénétrant qui arrivera il est petit et
charades et lille lui c'est un battant
alors lui le rat des villes
il est horrible c'est une mutation du
rat des champs est en fait le rat des
villes
il est super dangereux parce qu'il est
très intelligent encore plus que celui
de rat des champs et il fait il est
aussi simulateur se dire qu'il va faire
semblant d'être mort vous allez vous
approchez il va vous sautez à l'aloe sac
et d'envié simulateur s'accommode
commencé téléspectateurs tient les raves
ont été dominés dont 49 pour fournir et
51 personnes non mais je suis dit ça
fait vraiment pu et peut vous montrer
regardez ce qui se passe la nuit avec
les rats dans les grandes agglomérations
regardez cette vidéo qui a été tournée
dans le 10e arrondissement de paris
regardez les rats comment ils kiffent
quand on n'est pas là les images que
vous voyez sont résultats de
l'observation de la rue gustave
d'oublier pendant une heure un soir
comme tous les autres soirs et ce depuis
des semaines
voici maintenant la vue que j'ai de mes
fenêtres c'est tous les soirs comme ça
toutes les nuits comme ça alors on en
est là aujourd'hui et on a l'impression
que les pouvoirs publics
gage rien pour nous aider malgré nos
alertes répétées au manque d'hygiène
abominables dans ce passage et malgré et
ça c'est très grave les risques
d'atteinte à la santé publique notamment
celle des enfants
j'ai une information exclusive sur les
rats ou c'est qu'au 19e siècle les
habitants de paris étaient payés pour
tuer les rats brink's est prêt la prime
à la queue il fallait ramener en fait
une queue de rat pour prouver qu'on
avait tué haras est là en fait que la
mairie pâle en train d'organiser une
grande collecte de queues de rats voilà
il cherche 200 que draps pour faire des
études
c'est houphouet les sessad rue louis
gill il y en aurait entre 4 et 6
millions à paris aujourd'hui selon les
dernières estimations
et le problème c'est qu'avec les crues
de la seine également ils sont sortis
des berges de la seine et en ce moment
on ne sait plus comment les contenir ils
ont appris à contourner les pièges
habilitera je remets dans les trappes
ils sont également intelligent fini ça à
mes cd crème sur les grands contre elle
moi si j'étais avocat je me bats côté
nohra en 2010 huitième vidéo choc prise
sur un éboueur qui avait fait le buzz
j'aimerais qu'on la revoie vous allez me
dire si vous avez déjà vu ça des
colonies drap comme ça rien on va dans
le bac
[Musique]
vous faites week-end alors est ce que ça
vous est déjà arrivé ça c'est un bon
technicien
or vous vous déplacez pas c'est lui qui
met your own c'est lui qui aura sera
vous avez déjà vu ça qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire au vote en sabotant pas
autant c'est incroyable ça aurait pas
autant alors oui vu qu'on est en panique
est ce qu'on doit faire dans nos
appartements parisiens s'est scindé
petit koné petit truc à faire des petits
conseils
alors il n'y a pas de remède si vous
faites venir d'ailleurs c'est par elles
avaient beaucoup plus à paris mais il ya
tout dans toutes les grosses ça et aussi
marseille ce que vous pouvez faire à
votre niveau c'est de commencer déjà par
boucher les trous où vous voyez les
points d'entrée bat maintenant ok je
vais pas vous dire que c'est une
solution parce que la seule solution
quand vraiment voilà une maison qui a
infesté draw un appartement ou peu
importe c'est vraiment avec des
molécules que seuls des professeurs dans
les molécules on les met dans des poses
d'abattage sécurisé qui ferment à clé et
battages et post d'abattage donc de
sécuriser qui ferment à clé ou au monde
dispose des molécules à l'intérieur
d'accord est tout simplement les roms
viennent s'alimenter à l'intérieur
paraît qu'ils sont pondus après c'est ça
y'a pas une boîte à rat comme ça où est
un truc qu'il aura pris les pendules non
april se dessèchent en fait triste décès
d'accord et il me ressemble et sept
cadavres
adacore oui d'accord allait très bien il
paraît que les dairas c'est seulement au
rez de chaussée
non que ça va mal dans les étages non ça
c'est de chercher ils peuvent en a il
peut en avoir partout on a fait des fois
on traite d immeuble de 17 étages au 17e
étage il ya des mais alors comment ça se
passe
moi parce que ça que j'aimerais savoir
pour les téléspectateurs aussi c'est à
dire rien rats ils arrivent les gabonais
est long mais dont flat mois et genres
les autres arrivent comment il fait pour
repérer quand ils sont attirés comment
ils sont attirés alors la plupart du
temps ça va être la plupart des
infestations c'est dans des endroits à
proximité de deux restaurants voilà deux
les uns d'alimentation par exemple mais
aujourd'hui tout ça ça ne veut plus rien
dire il peut en avoir plein partout
ouais alors regarder pourquoi ils
prolifèrent les rats parce que un seul
couple devra cesser capable à lui tout
seul d'engendrer une colonie de
plusieurs milliers d'autres en quelques
mois 07 vous être à me faire se
reproduit extrêmement vite
prenons un couple de rats au bout de
deux mois
la femelle peut avoir une première
portée d'une dizaine de petits chats
kraton se reproduit à son tour au bout
de 12 mois
la population atteint déjà près de 1000
individus en 24 mois
notre couple de rats or à engendrer une
descendance de près de 45000 rongeurs
c'est ça ouais vous porter par an tous
portés par un moyenne de 5,6 petit
faites le calcul
et c'est vraiment dommage parce que ça
quand même un rôle de nettoyeur même les
chiens savants les élimine tous en aura
un autre problème
alors j'ai eu à me wade a la rage il ya
un problème quand même à exactement je
vous le dis et y'a un truc c'est que les
touristes aussi
alors bon maintenant c'est complètement
ne veulent plus venir aussi à paris ou
dans les grandes villes parce qu'il ya
trop draps regardez cette vidéo de
touristes qui filme en pleine journée
des rats s'attaquant à une poubelle près
de la tour eiffel est ce que vous êtes
attaqués à appeler comme ça souvent
aussi pour des poubelles pour des trucs
ou pas du tout oui oui également comme
donc dans les poubelles il en est
généralement dans les immeubles dans
dans les endroits où on met toutes les
poubelles donc dans les locales dans les
local technique dans les parties
communes des immeubles
après il peut en avoir aussi tout autant
dans des appartements
c'est partout partout partout exactement
c'est vous sentez vraiment qu'une
recrudescence en ce moment en ce moment
oui beaucoup
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
avec les cadets champions et attaquer
allemand qui vous appelle qui vous
disons j'ai été mordu par un oui ça
m'est arrivé ben justement la semaine
dernière accor s'est passé et
une personne en monsieur a un petit peu
âgée qui a été bloquée dans son lit qui
ne pouvait pas bouger et qui m'a appelé
complètement paniquée me disant écoutez
faut venez tout de suite je ne sais pas
du tout quoi faire j'ai remarqué que
j'avais un rat chez moi qui ai passé une
fois la semaine dernière donc c'est une
semaine avant que le rae est passé chez
lui le monsieur n'a rien fait il est
passé juste à la maison comme ça qu'on
verrait ça ça arrive comme ça les rats
avant de venir s'installer en colonie
sylvain qui vient d'abord visite
exactement et donc ouais et donc ils
avaient donc le monsieur me disais donc
je dormais une nuit dans mon lit et le
rat est monté sur mon lit et m'a mordu à
la jambe en découdre est en train de
dormir et un rat qui vous mord à la
jambe car quelle race rare et laura a
pris les parties leur après le monsieur
a fait appel a justement à nous pour
qu'on pût lisez donc ce qu'on a fait
c'est un traitement complet on restera
non non on les retrouve pas les rats
alors dans un traitement on vient pas
chasser le rpt à l'attraper à l'eau
claire haimer pas le rameur bien sûr il
va mais justement donc le procédé c'est
ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure
c'est que laura vient manger le produit
convient disposés par toucher les gens
et paris maintenant ils reconnaissent
aussi les produits de plus en plus et
que l on leur fait plus genre il
arrivait finances assez alors ce que
vous dites c'est vrai au niveau des
molécules aujourd'hui que qu'on utilise
les rats vont s'adapter de plus en plus
c'est pour ça que c'est devenu très
compliqué aujourd'hui de pouvoir les
éliminer maintenant il faut avoir accès
à certaines molécules et si vous voulez
les professionnels ont accès aux
molécules qui vont permettre justement
aura par contre ce qu'on vend dans le
commerce dans tous les commerces qu'on
vend directement aux particuliers
ça sert à rien ça marche pas regardez
cette image des touristes regarder
et là vous dites les rats n'ont pas peur
on a l'impression qu'ils ont peur a
quand même bon oui il y en a qui s'en va
oui non ces paroles sont quand même au
film de wes herrett film d'assez près
travaux et boire qui cela exactement
mais c'est vrai bravo merci en tout cas
les gars d'être venu nous voir
franchement merci pour votre témoignage
et vous allez nous faire flipper moitié
dormir sur la tête de ma mère mais
dormir en combinant un tabouret